dr. Carson thank you for joining us on
Sky News first of all it's your campaign
in crisis no you have said that if there
are backroom deals among senior
Republicans that you'd be out of here
are you paving the way for an exit well
no I'm just telling the truth I don't
want to be a part of anything that
thoughts the will of the people so you
know as long as things they're open and
consistent with integrity I have no
problem with it but once you start
manipulating and and porting the will of
people that's not something I want to be
a part of I think Donald Trump might
think that he's everybody's main rival
what do people see in him I think they
see a lot of bravado a lot of confidence
and in a situation where we've just gone
through several years where you know
there seems to be uncertainty that can
be something that's very appealing to
people in the past you've said that you
don't believe climate change should be
politicized does that mean that as
president you wouldn't have attended the
summit in Paris whether I would have or
not it certainly would not have been the
thing that I would have thought was the
premier issue in the world and the cause
of terrorism and everything of that
nature I just don't which is gone I may
well have gone do you think it's
president that your ring would be
engaged and informed enough on climate
change to treat it with the significance
that I think the world now recognizes I
would treat it with significance that I
think it deserves but I would not make
it the overarching driver of all my
policies what is climate change well if
you look at the world in the history of
the world at all points in time
temperatures are going up or
temperatures are going down if you don't
remember because you're too young but in
the 70s you know in the front of
Newsweek magazine it was a big glacier
because we're entering the new ice
and then later on it was we're gonna all
burn up everything's kind of mouse and
then it was wow we don't know which one
it is so let's just call it change now
if when when things stopped changing
then we're dead your views have been
called eccentric I'm referring to
specific such as you'll be that the
pyramids were built to store grain that
if the Jews had had guns the Holocaust
could have been prevented that Obamacare
is worse than slavery you're obviously
entitled to those views but the fact is
a lot of people do find them alienating
some find them laughable do you think
you'd have to rein yourself in as
president well first of all recognize
for instance with the with the grain
deal you know somebody goes back 20
years to a private talk where I said you
know that's a feasible possibility and
of course anybody who's objective can go
back and find it I'm not the first one
to think that and there are
hieroglyphics showing people carrying
grain out of there so you know I don't
think that that's such a while thing but
that's not something that I've been
sitting around talking about and
advocating that's something that
somebody's going back digging up and
trying to say oh this is a really
strange thing you know that's the case
with a lot of this stuff I think it I
understand that the news media you know
they're supposed to vet people and you
know if there's scandals and things of
course you want to know about them in my
case they can't find any scandals
therefore well let's see if we can
somehow make this guy look crazy you
know and I just think it's so dishonest
do you recognize that some of your views
on what you would call mainstream could
that be alienating in the role of
President Oh give me an example I've
given you three exactly which one do you
want to talk about I just talked about
one of them those particular views and
in terms of weapons for example that the
Holocaust would have happened a lot of
people well wait a minute I never said
that did I say that I said if they had
had weapons it would have been more
difficult and that's the reason that
they disarmed them first and that is
typical of tyrants they don't want to
have a difficult time so they disarmed
people that was the point
that's not an outrageous thing you know
could the world take America seriously
with you as president I believe it could
absolutely I think the world's not used
to having somebody who speaks
straightforward and honestly now you
have been criticized for a lack of
knowledge on foreign policy but in your
book a more perfect union you say you
were fortunate enough to visit 50
countries so with that experience in
mind
58 now 58 right okay so with that in
mind who do you think is America's key
ally in the modern world well you know
that's one of the problems that's going
on right now our allies can't trust us
because we tend not to be trustworthy
you know we've turned our backs on
Israel you know there was a gentlemen's
agreement in Ukraine that if they got
rid of their nuclear arsenal and
something happened we would be there for
them were we
of course not I just think that what we
really need to do is shore up our
relationships particularly with all of
our NATO allies but also in the Middle
East you know we have traditionally you
know had good relationships with it you
know Egypt Jordan you know Kuwait
Morocco you know with a whole host of
places and why are they not
enthusiastically joining us in a
coalition because we are untrustworthy
to agree that they're sitting there
wondering if we line up with us and then
they decide they're not going to support
us we're facing the full wrath of Isis
by ourselves so they're kind of sitting
on the fence and we need to abolish the
thought that we are not trustworthy
Donald Trump has said that London has a
Muslim problem is he right and do you
think that Europe has a Muslim problem
and how would you fix that
well I guess it depends on what your
wants guess it depends on what London
wants do are they happy with a society
where you know they're multiple Sharia
Courts and enclaves of people who
perhaps have a different way of living
and a different standard of living so do
you agree with Donald Trump that there
are no go zones well what I just said is
it depends on what they want if they
don't want that then it's a problem
if they want that then it's not a
problem
yes Stan yes of course place is the way
you can't go I don't know whether you
can go there or not but there are
certainly places that have a different
way of life and they're enclaves like
that what do you think should be done
about that well it depends on what the
people in that country want they want
safety it's it's sort of like you may
remember a few years ago in Australia
when the Prime Minister said look people
want to come here from other places and
I understand that and it's a nice place
we love it and we love our culture and
if you want to come here and assimilate
to our culture you're welcome and if you
don't there are other places you can go
and that that was the philosophy and
turned out to be a very popular
philosophy you know if London wants that
if England wants that they ought to make
that declaration and if they don't want
that and if they're quite willing to
change that's fine to US citizens being
radicalized online it's a problem we've
seen that recently how do you stop that
happening well first of all I think you
need to monitor the internet much
greater extent I think you need to put
out Connor message and I think you need
to be involved in cyber attacks does the
Muslim community need to play a bigger
role they need to play a much bigger
role the Imams the clerics and the
community it's
it's going to be obviously much more
endearing to the rest of the population
if the Muslim population is the one
pointing out who the radicals are do you
think you were endearing to the Muslim
population when you said that their
faith was inconsistent with the
Constitution well I said that if they
embraced the entirety of Islam including
Sharia law Sharia law is not compatible
with the American Constitution I don't
think anybody can disagree with that
what about this use guns the number of
Americans killed by guns usually
outnumbers those killed by terrorism
isn't that the key job for any president
to sort that out it already is sorted
out in the sense that we have a
constitution with a second amendment
that guarantees people the right to keep
and bear arms so does that mean that we
shouldn't be looking at ways to keep
dangerous weapons out of the hands of
people who are mentally unstable sure we
could still look at that
but not in any way compromising the
Second Amendment so you think the gun
problem is already sorted out courtesy
of the Second Amendment that the problem
is not guns the problem is people we
know that President Obama enjoys several
rounds of golf what would president
Carlson do to kick back and relax
probably pay pool I enjoy playing feels
very relaxing him and my wife is an
excellent pool player she became an
excellent pool player after we got
married because she realized I enjoyed
it a lot who is I generally when other
if if in any way I slack off she'll win